Bridget: Hi, I'm Bridget Hillyer.
I'm one of the organizers at Strange Loop.
In this series we've been talking to previous
speakers.
But now that we have a program for this year
we're talking to some feature speakers, Strange
Loop is on in person this year.
It's September 30th through October 2nd, 2021
in St. Louis, Missouri USA.
You can find out more information and get
tickets at the website.
https://thestrangeloop.com.
Also this year, we have a virtual option.
So if you aren't able to make it in person,
you can still be part of the conference.
So you can also find out information about
that on the website.
Today I'm delighted to have Tejas Chopra right
here who will be speaking this year in October.
And the name of his talk is Carbon Footprint
Aware Software Development.
Thanks for being with me today, it will be
nice to talk to you.
Tejas: Yes, same here, Bridget.
And thank you everyone for listening again.
And I'm excited to talk about carbon footprint
and software.
Bridget: So today I'd just like to talk about
some background and some things around carbon
footprint aware software development.
So my first question, when I saw your talk
and that the abstract.
What I was first curious about is what led
you to be interested in carbon footprint aware
software development?
Was it something you would worked on, you
know, some knowledge you had something in
your background.
Tejas: Yeah, that's that's a great question.
I think it's a, it's a series of steps that
led me to where I am.
The first thing I would say is that I got
interested in Bitcoin in the year 2013, 2014,
just when it was very nascent.
And one of the things with Bitcoin was that,
oh, it's an energy gobbler.
So I started reading more about it, more about
proof of work.
And I saw that, yes, in fact, Bitcoin actually
consumes a lot of energy today.
And that actually led me to take a step back.
And look at other areas of my life, where,
you know, I'm seeing carbon footprint increase
in carbon footprint and there are two ways.
Really one thing is as a human being, you
use a lot of services.
You use your smartphone, you use the internet,
you use a car.
So those are things that you can definitely
choose to buy stuff appropriately.
And the other thing is, as a software developer,
you work on software.
And it's when I tried to research what into
it.
I realized that 4% of the total carbon footprint
on this planet is contributed by software.
So I know that it is not 4% seems very minuscule
compared to, you know, 20%, 30% that we have
out there with cars, with with you know, agriculture
and other things.
So, but if you can make a dent in that 4%,
because that is completely in your control.
That would really go a long way in trying
to make this planet better.
So that was what was the motivation that I
had.
And then I connected it back to what I had
learned in school.
So I'm from Carnegie Mellon university.
In school, we had lectures around, you know,
how can you write more efficient software?
And then I tried to club these two thoughts
together.
Can we write software that is efficient?
Better for the environment.
And there are simple techniques as software
engineers that you can employ in your day-to-day
life.
So that's where, you know, these dots connected
and that's how I got interested into it.
And I've been using it in my work since that
point on, and I am a strong advocate of, you
know, having making a change in the environment
because we should always leave back the world
better than what we got it.
So that's the motivation.
Bridget: So Bitcoin, I'm not surprised to
hear that, that, that was an inspiration there.
I think when people think about this topic,
that's the first thing they think of because
there's a lot of talk about it.
So based on what you've learned, what do you
think the hope is for Bitcoin?
For what could be done there to reduce the
carbon footprint?
Tejas: Sure.
Sure.
So one thing is that there is also a misnomer
out there that Bitcoin energy is like Bitcoin
is really bad for the environment.
It is bad because it uses a lot of energy,
but if you compare it to the industries that
is trying to disrupt such as traditional banking
or gold, the energy usage in those areas or
those industries is still much higher than
Bitcoin.
And if you look at what the aim of Bitcoin
is, it is to actually give financial independence
to people that are not really reached out
by traditional banking.
So it really will make people's lives better.
So in that sense, I still feel that, you know,
the energy usage in Bitcoin is a problem,
but there are far bigger problems as well
out there for, for reducing the energy consumption.
That's the first point.
The second point is that yes, proof of work
is bad for the environment.
So it is, unfortunately the way Bitcoin is
designed, it will keep using proof of work.
There are alternatives such as Ethereum, which
use proof of stake.
And with Ethereum 2.0 the amount of energy
will go down by 99.9%.
When 2.0 just comes out.
So that's the other thing.
I have seen that recently, Bitcoin proof of
work algorithms like the mining farms and
oil, they are using renewable energy sources
at locations where previously we were not
able to tap into them.
So a very good example is El Salvador, which
is introducing Bitcoin.
They actually want to mine it using the volcano
that they have so energy from the volcano.
So I think these are interesting ideas that
people are coming up with.
To circumvent the problems and these ideas
can also be applied in other industries.
So it's not really a lose, lose.
I still feel that there is something to gain
from our experience with Bitcoin and with
increase in usability, increase in scalability
things will get better.
That's what I think.
Yeah.
Bridget: It's nice to talk to somebody who
has some real perspective on, on it and has
thought through the problems as opposed to
just "Bitcoin is bad for the environment.
What do we do?"
So you work at Netflix and it's I think anybody
would hear that and hear you talking about
a carbon footprint of where software development
would then have the question, right?
So what is Netflix doing?
And, and if when you're thinking about things
like that, like Bitcoin, Netflix has the potential
to have a lot of impact if they were to employ
things that improved their carbon footprint.
So how has that affected how you look at how
software development works at Netflix.
Tejas: And this is a very pertinent question
because especially now that we are all in
remote work, in some ways the streaming industry
has boomed.
We have so many streaming providers and Netflix
has 200 million subscribers, 200 million plus
subscribers.
So any dent that we can make in this space
goes a long way to improve the environment.
And it's also a very pertinent time actually,
because recently the carbon trust group did
a study.
It's an independent group and they claimed
in the study that an hour of streaming a Netflix
movie in the UK the amount of energy that
it uses is equivalent to boiling the kettle
for six minutes or like popping four bags
of popcorn in a microwave.
So in that sense this has an, just to give
you numbers there it's 55 grams of carbon
dioxide released in the air by streaming a
Netflix movie for an hour.
50% of it is contributed by the last mile,
which is the user's phone or users device.
Which really you cannot control beyond an
extent.
50% of it is then the network infrastructure,
the data centers, the REST request calls,
all of those taking up energy.
And Netflix has gotten really better at it
because at the start of the year it was around
a hundred grams of carbon dioxide for an hour,
at least by some study.
And now it is down to 55 grams.
And it really has gotten better over the years.
So we are aiming to be greenhouse emission
neutral.
I think that's the word by 2022.
So in that sense, we we are as a company,
very invested in you know, making the environment
better.
And Netflix again has two parts to it.
There is a physical production where you actually
produce movies and then there is a streaming
part of it.
The physical production is the one that generates
a lot more carbon dioxide or has a bigger
energy footprint than the streaming part.
So to offset that we would then buy credits
carbon credits and that's how we'll get carbon
neutral.
So that's what Netflix is doing on that front.
And I personally work on the storage infrastructure
side.
So I work as a part of a team that builds
storage solutions for Netflix Studios and
streaming platforms.
And we have petabytes to exabytes of storage
that we deal with at Netflix.
So what we try to do in our day-to-day work
is, you know, write efficient code that reduces
the footprint of storage in the cloud which
effectively then boils down to how much energy
gets used in the cloud.
One thing is that you pay for it and you have
money for it and that's fine.
Like Netflix has money, but the other thing
is, is this good for the environment?
And that's the bigger motivation for us as
engineers here.
Also in my day-to-day work, I'm translating
all these ideas into software techniques,
for example, a simple thing like removing
dead code right.
You may think that fine if you don't remove
it, it's just lying there, but it actually
takes up energy cycles to, you know, process
it and not actually execute that dead code.
So in some ways these little steps having
event driven architectures versus polling
based architectures, they are things that
reduce your CPU usage and then translate into
a better experience for the environment.
So these are things that, you know on top
of my head that I can think of that we are
doing as engineers.
Bridget: Well, that's great to hear that Netflix
and especially with the, those aggressive
targets, like by 2022, that's that's great
to hear that's comforting.
So some of the things you've talked about
with the various points at which there's energy
consumption looking ahead to what the techniques
are for carbon footprint aware software development.
Something I find as a software developer and,
and doing profiling of things, one of the
real big principles that you run into and,
and, what you run into in practice is knowing
what you're actually measuring.
You know, if, if you're measuring you know
CPU cycle, or memory usage of something, it's
when you do the measurement, are you actually
measuring the thing that you have that you
can make an impact on.
So thinking about that what are your thoughts
about how, what metrics there would be to
see that you're improving things?
And then how do you actually do the measuring
on that.
Tejas: That's a great question.
And that's actually what I aspire to do.
As part of, you know, my job where today,
when you write code, you have unit tests that
catch your bugs and you have integration tests.
You deploy your code.
There are a bunch of tests that run, and then
you know that whether it's good or not.
And I aspire to make a framework where, you
know, it's not just a functionally correct
code, but environmentally good code.
So you will have a framework or a series of
tests that you can run that, like you said,
measure the memory usage, measure the CPU
cycles of your code, measure, the amount of
spin spinning of your like if you have spin
locks anywhere or detecting those kinds of
things in your code and give you alternatives
for those also stuff what compilers do these
days, right?
Loop unrolling, some of these things that
you can do on your end.
I think these would be good starting points.
And then you can use a lot of static analysis
tools that are already available in coding.
So they would be a great starting point and
then like you said, you know, flame graphs
are a good way to know which function is being
hit the most.
And you can then get into that like which
particular function needs to be optimized
the most for energy.
So those are some of the tricks that you can
start off with.
Bridget: So one of the things that has got
me interested in this topic is I, I did a
lot of research and thought a lot about changing
jobs or, you know, moving in a professional
direction to do something towards having some
impact on climate change, you know, not that
I was going to figure out anything that solves
anything, but, you know, just try to move
over into some industry that that has more
of an impact.
And in the course of doing that I found out
a lot and, and made some decisions based on
that.
But I also talked to a lot of people, a lot
of software developers in my network who are
interested in the same thing.
I've heard this from so many people.
How do you think taking a look at the impact
on climate change via the lens of carbon footprint
aware software development how does that what
advice would you give somebody who's thinking
about that would it be better to say go work
at Tesla and help them produce electric cars,
which is, you know, it's direct impact and
climate change or using what you know about
software development to make an impact on
how software and services impact on climate
change.
Like it put another way if I go work at Facebook
and I know these methods and I can reduce
their carbon footprint by 0.0, zero, whatever
1% given how, how big their service is versus
doing something that's direct, like electrical
cars or solar panels.
What advice would you give somebody in, in
weighing those two options?
Tejas: Sure, sure.
And I, I truly believe that electric cars
are the future.
If you look at the world of 40, 50 years from
now, what will the world look like?
I think it will be electric cars.
It'll be cars that drive themselves, probably
not even cars.
I don't even know what all will be there,
but I do believe that, you know at that scale
it would make a lot of sense for anyone to,
you know, look for a career in building those.
So definitely that would be the first pick,
but a lot of us don't have options because
electric cars haven't reached a lot of countries
in the world.
People do not have the technology to get there
yet.
So do you, as an engineer, wait till that
comes over or do you try to move the needle?
However, tiny it is.
So, you know, do your own little bit in your
day to day work.
And Facebook is a great example, right?
Like if you look at WhatsApp, the number of
people it touches is like 2 billion plus in
the world.
So if you look at 0.001% of that, it's still
a bigger number compared to let's say Tesla
two years back where it was just still a tiny
fraction of the number of cars or emissions
that happen.
I agree that with time we will come to a place
where we would, everyone would be working
on something that is directly correlated to
the environment.
So if I were sitting in California, I would
prefer Tesla going and making electric cars.
But if I'm sitting in some remote corner of
the world where I don't have many options,
I can still try to work at some other company
and write software something that I live and
breathe in a way that, you know, can help
the environment or move the needle a little
bit.
So I think no matter where you are, you can
always find a way to do the right thing.
So, yeah.
Bridget: That's some really good perspective.
Something I've continued to think about and
a lot of people I know do Thank you so much,
Tejas.
I, this is, this has been great really interesting
topic.
And I'm very much looking forward to your
talk.
Can't wait to see you in person at Strange
Loop in October.
Thanks so much for agreeing to speak at the
conference.
Tejas: Absolutely.
And I look forward to talking to everyone
and finally coming out of this pandemic and
meeting in person.